[Music]  is indescribable  to work with creative people especially  people who make movies it is such a  thrill it's overwhelming when I think  about it  and I keep saying you know myself I  can't believe this is me I can't believe  I lucked out something you never forget  and thank you for all of this and I hope  that I didn't set interviewing back a  few decades I'll see you later  thank you I remember every cameo I've  done since the first one I think I'm a  very lucky guy  this is the fight of our lives we are  getting the whole team right oh it's a  regular sized man hey guys  is that everyone you wanted more  are you crying this is my destiny  Avengers Assemble  [Applause]  [Music]  give me that you have the little one  [Music]